The thing I want to do next is say let's just deal with a single row at a time.
Let's not worry about the rest of the row. Let's now worry about going in columns.
Just deal with one row but also have that row handle the cross letters--the cross words.
I'm going to need a representation for a row, and I think I'm going to make that be a list.
There are many possible choices, but a list is good.
I choose a list rather than a tuple, because I want to be able to change it in place.
I want to be able to modify the row as we go, as the game evolves.
Row is going to be a list of squares.
If the square is a letter, we'll just use that letter as the value of the square.
If the square is an empty spot which has nothing in it,
I think I'll use dot just to say nothing is there.
A trick that you learn once you've done this kind of thing a lot of times,
is to say I'm going to be look at letters, I'm going to be looking at locations in the row,
I'm going to be looking at their adjacent letters and going to the right
and going to the left.
If I'm trying to fill in from this anchor, I'll move to the left to put in the prefix
and I'll move to the right to extend the word.
It seems to me like I'm always going to have to be making checks of saying
what's the next character, is it a letter, is it an anchor, what is it?
Also, oops, did I get past the end of the board.
It seems like I'm going to have to duplicate the amount of code I have to write to check
both the case when I go off the board and when I don't go off the board.
One way to avoid that is to make sure you never go off the board.
It cuts the amount of code in half to some extent.
A way to do that is to put in extra squares--
to say here are the squares on the board, but let's make another extra square on each side
and just fill that in say the value of what's in that square is a boarder,
not a real square that you can play in, but if I'm here and I say what's the value of square
number i -1, I get an answer saying it's a border rather than getting an answer
that's saying when you go i - 1 from position 0 you get an error.
I think I'll use a vertical bar to indicate a border.
I'll have one there, and at the end of my row, I'll have another border.
Now I've sort of got everything. I got borders, letters, empty squares.
The only thing left is anchors.
I think what I'll do here is I'll introduce a special type for anchor.
I could have used something like a tuple or a set of characters,
but I want to make sure I know, and I want to have something in my code
that says if the value of row[ i ] is an instance of anchor, then I want to do something.
So we'll make anchor be a class, and I want it to be a class that contains the set of letters.
I can do that in a very easy way.
I can use a class statement to say I'm going to define a new class.
The class is called an anchor, and the class is a subset of the set class.
Then I don't need anything else for the definition of the class.
All I have to know is that anchors are a type of set, but they're a particular type of set.
They're a set of anchor letters. Here's a code for that.
I define a class of anchor. I have all of my allowable letters.
Then I say any is an anchor, which allows you to put any letter onto that anchor spot.
Now I want to represent this row where here are the borders, here are the empty spots,
and here are the particular letters, and this representation--
the schematic representation as a string does not account for a fact
that after the A we're going to have
two restricted anchors that have to contain these characters.
So we'll define them--use the names mnx and moab to be the two anchors
that are restricted to have only those letters.
Now our row is equal to the border square is element number 0.
Then the A is element number 1.
Then we have these two restricted anchors, two more empty spots,
another anchor where anything can go--the B and the E, and so on.